in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Edie
and Teresa are with us hey guys how are
you yeah yeah welcome welcome thanks for
coming by where do you guys live
Bakersfield California
no that's a bit more than coming by you
had to come all the way across the
United States my goodness we'll welcome
to Nashville good to have you it's glad
to be here
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream correct and how much have you
paid off two hundred twenty thousand
five hundred and sixty nine dollars and
some change
Wow why did it go and how long did that
take uh seven years okay and your range
of income during that seven years when
we first started I actually was late got
laid off right when we started the class
and I was making unemployment so we were
making about seventy maybe seventy five
thousand at that time mm-hmm and now
we're up to about 120 good for you guys
what do y'all do for a living I am a
accounts receivable supervisor mm-hmm
and I work for the County Sheriff as a
civilian employee why don't their ecoo
good good so I'm gonna guess and say
this might be your house you paid off
correct I'm looking at weird people yeah
paid for house what's that house worth
pretty close to 300,000 Wow yeah I had
sent a picture to Kelly of the front of
our house with our beaters sitting in a
driveway I'm driving an 18 year old
pickup truck
Teresa's driving a 11 year old car and
now that we're debt-free we're saving up
for a new car for her I know used cars
yeah they I love it well good for you
guys well done well done you have a
paid-for house how old are you very cool
decided that it's never too late to get
this started and we'd wanted to be
debt-free yeah when we retire at 65 well
you will be you are you did it yeah with
five years to spare good job well done
well done man that just puts you in an
unusually good position how does it feel
to not have any payments of any kind
that's indescribable for me anyway send
Theresa
we I just felt great it feels great to
wake up every morning and know that we
don't know anybody anything but
ourselves I love it yes that's so fun
yeah we saw so much believed in this
program that we started as coordinators
the surface year of doing it
Wow yeah thank you and we also this past
summer we did the generator change and
we just see some remarkable changes
that's happened in our church there
wasn't a program at our church so we
asked our pastors if we can do this and
they said absolutely and and we've just
been enjoying it and we enjoy seeing
people's lives change and and everyone
getting excited and we always only said
we need to start with the teens and
that's what we did this past year Wow so
teaching the teenagers as well they're
cool well thank you for leading the
class it's fun to lead though very
rewarding yeah watching these people's
lives change right in front of your eyes
exactly what he's thinking and now
they're coordinators got their house
paid for so you're like the ultimate
inspiration exactly way to go very cool
so you went to the class seven years ago
Financial Peace University we it was
funny because like I said I got laid off
and we were debating whether I should
pay the hundred dollars for the class
and we prayed about it and God laid it
on our hands at our hearts that we need
to do this and we we had a few bucks in
the bank but I said let's do it so we
signed up and like the first second
video class that we went through we're
driving home and we just looked at each
other at the stoplight and said man
what's it going to be like when we get
we didn't know when we were going to be
debt-free but I said we can do this
we're going to be debt-free yes and the
rest is history
yeah and you didn't even have a job
right there now I faith in god so yeah
absolutely well I mean you know and you
know you're gonna be okay it's just a
matter of what so you know how ugly it's
gonna get before it turns around and
turned it right around that's right
between the two of us we have six kids
15 grandkids and we wanted to to show
them that it can be done yeah Wow
so what are they saying
they are they cheering you on yes yeah
yes our son is with us today and he's
been through the class and he's he's
working the work in the program so I
love it yeah it's really great but you
know we along the route we did before we
took the class we did some really dumb
stuff you know we we had bought a
timeshare and then we paid $2,000 for a
pizza one time no it was like we went
out for a pizza and next door was a gym
like three years for the price of one so
we said while the pizzas being cooked
let's go next door and see well they
were very impulsive so they talked us
into a 2,000 dollar contracts
congratulations on getting this buying
job yeah I'm so proud of you very very
well done well we're gonna give you a
signed copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired thank you and that's the that's
the next chapter you're gonna retire
inspired I mean that was the goal here
you're on your way and you're definitely
definitely in position to do that
well I'm very very proud of you what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is budget the written budget
yeah and sticking to it and it may seem
like it's it's hard at first but just
like anything else if you stick to it
it's like breathing you know it does
change everything it changes in a
lifetime it's a lifestyle change it's
just a matter and I love what Rachel's
saying with the new book love your life
not there she's saying budget is
permission to spend could you you know
you've got control and you can know you
can afford this and or you know you
can't afford it right now it's right
there in front of you but it's
permission to do things without stress
it really does increase the
communication and lower the stress level
yeah and just like when we take
vacations when we take vacations we
budget for the year and we know we paint
everything in cash we when we come home
there is no bill in the mail saying we
owe on our credit card there you go the
vacation doesn't follow your home's
restaurant no very good stuff all right
add a Teresa Bakersfield California 200
$21,000 paid off in seven years that's
their house and everything baby-making
75 to 120 through that seven years the
range counted down let's hear a debt
free scream three well
well done you two well done and that's
fabulous that's as it should be
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in company